Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Dr. Robert Waldinger, who's the director
of the Harvard Study of Adult Development
and also coauthor of the new book The Good
Life Lessons from the World's Longest Scientific
Study of Happiness.
Really great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Well, it's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So one of the really interesting
things about this study, which started in
1938, is many studies on happiness are of
different groups of people, sometimes from
different countries across different time
periods.
And it can become very difficult to really
compare apples to apples for, for lack of
a better term.
And one of the interesting things about this
study that now has gone on for more than eight
decades is it followed the same individuals
and families.
It's very extensive, asked a ton of questions,
hundreds of measurements, includes bloodwork,
brain scans.
I mean, you're really approaching this from
a sort of cover every aspect perspective.
Can you tell us just a little bit about how
this study started, the number of people that
were originally part of it and the number
that that are still with us today?
Speaker 2: Sure.
That started as two studies that didn't know
about each other started on different parts
of the Harvard University campus.
One was a study begun at Harvard Health Service,
the student health Service with sophomores
from Harvard College, and the other was a
study of delinquency, a study of delinquent
and non delinquent boys from Boston's poorest
neighborhoods, from the most troubled families.
268 Harvard College undergraduates, 456 inner
city boys and all of them were studied as
a way to understand thriving, how kids moved
from childhood into adulthood on good developmental
paths, including the kids who were born with
so many strikes against them, you know, into
such disadvantaged circumstances.
So it was radical for its time to be doing
these studies of human thriving.
And then eventually my predecessor put the
two studies together and started looking at
them as contrasting groups.
Speaker 1: When we look at the popular literature
on happiness, there are all these often repeated
ideas or rules of thumb or whatever the case
may be.
One of them is once you make $75,000 a year,
it's equivalent.
When you get beyond that, you're not really
anymore.
Sometimes the term is satisfied with your
life.
Sometimes the term happy is used.
Another one that you often hear is later in
life.
Having spent more time in the office rarely
correlates to more happiness.
Whereas having spent more time with family
and having more close relationships does.
And, you know, then five years go by and there's
another study that comes out and it has a
slightly different, different result on some
of those sort of like lowest hanging fruit
things that are often discussed.
What has this study determined?
Speaker 2: Well, we determined that the inner
city group was no less happy than the privileged
Harvard group, and that's more consistent
with other studies that say basically, once
you get your basic economic needs met, then
making more and more money doesn't do it,
doesn't increase your happiness.
And that seems to be a pretty robust findings
across a lot of groups of people.
Speaker 1: Is there something to that $75,000
number that you found?
Speaker 2: No, not 75,000 per say.
And of course, it varies depending on whether
you live in the middle of New York City or
live in rural Iowa.
Right.
It's really the question of when, when you
have your basic needs met.
Once you've gotten to that point in terms
of income, then more money doesn't do it for
you.
Then you can make millions more and on average,
people aren't happier.
Speaker 1: There's this phrase nobody is on
their deathbed wishing they spent more time
at the office.
Right.
You hear that very often?
Yeah.
What is the study have to say about that dynamic?
Speaker 2: Well, we asked people when our
first generation folks were in their eighties.
We asked them to look back on their lives
and we asked, what are you proudest of and
what do you regret the most?
And what they regretted the most, particularly
the men.
Because this was the World War two generation
they regretted the most.
Spending too much time at work and not spending
enough time with the people they cared about.
What they were proudest of was was to a person,
something to do with their relationships.
So, you know, they didn't say I made a ton
of money or I won all these awards, you know,
or I was famous.
And we had people who were all of those things.
They said I was a good boss, I was a good
spouse.
I was a good friend, a good parent.
Right.
So when they were looking back on what was
most meaningful, it wasn't about achievement.
It was about connections.
Speaker 1: Is it true that John F Kennedy
was one of the original participants?
Speaker 2: It is true.
And the only reason I can tell you that is
because he was outed by another journalist
about 15 years ago.
Otherwise, we are bound to keep in confidence
the identities of all of the people in our
study.
So, you know, in fact, the book has stories
of real people woven all through the book.
But the names and the superficial details
are disguised to make sure that we protect
their privacy.
Speaker 1: So it sounds like money beyond
a certain level, not a big contributor to
happiness, fame, not a big contributor to
happiness.
Having spent a lot of time at the office,
not not necessarily a contributor.
Relationships of of different kinds.
Yes.
Family, friendships, etc..
What else are the kind of positively correlated
stories that that you find?
Speaker 2: Taking care of your health matters
a lot.
You know, it's it's like our grandmothers
could have told us that.
But what we find and lots of studies find
is that, you know, getting regular health
care, not smoking, not abusing the alcohol
and drugs, regular exercise, not becoming
obese, all of those things make huge differences
in years of life lived and also in years of
healthy life.
So it really matters a lot to take care of
your health.
The surprising thing for us was the finding
about relationships being so important, because
at first we thought, well, how could relationships
actually get into your body and and change
your physiology?
And now for the last ten years we've been
studying that many other groups have, too,
And we're understanding that this is a very
powerful, robust connection between relationships
and physical health.
Speaker 1: What about religion?
Because there is religion can be a tough one
where it can be hard to separate the effect
of being part of a community and the social
aspects versus the religiosity itself.
And there's many, many studies on this.
Did you find anything that would be sort of
clear in the data about religious participation?
Speaker 2: Well, we asked people, do you have
a religious practice?
Do you have a spiritual practice?
And there were people who did and there were
people who did not.
And when we compare those two groups, neither
group was, on average, happier.
Hmm.
So didn't make a difference in your happiness,
whether you were spiritual or religious or
not.
But many of the religious and spiritual people
said that during times of difficulty, their
spiritual practice.
It says we're helpful to that.
Speaker 1: So that's more, I guess, qualitative
and quantitative.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
But quantitatively, when you compare the two
groups, no one group isn't happier.
Speaker 1: What about travel?
Because one of the things that's often written
about travel is because when you travel, you're
not in your routine.
Time seems to go by slower, which often one
of the things we read is that over time, you
know, years go by very, very quickly.
And part of this seems to be that there's
no cognitive difference day to day when you're
kind of in your in your normal day to day
thing.
So that travel is an interesting way.
And when one might think there might be some
correlation to happiness as well there.
Is there anything.
Speaker 2: We did not study that specifically.
But what you're saying makes a lot of sense.
And and what we do find is that more cognitive
stimulation keeps us sharper over time, and
that includes being connected with other people.
So one of the effects we think of relationships
on keeping our brains healthy is that it stimulates
us.
People are always unpredictable.
They're moving targets.
What you're going to say to me next is something
I don't know, right?
And that keeps my brain clicking on all cylinders.
That's a good thing for the brain.
And I think what you're pointing out is that
travel can do the same thing.
That's why time seems to go more slowly during
travel because we're like on alert.
Like, what am I going to see now?
How do I find my way here?
It's it's all of those challenges that we
think keeps us healthy cognitively as we get
older.
Speaker 1: One of the things that is it's
not unique to the United States, but it's
certainly been written about a lot in the
United States, is the trend that people move
relatively frequently in modern American society
much more commonly than in other parts of
the world, don't live near their families,
nor where they grew up.
I was recently reading Jared Diamond's book
about traditional societies, and he said,
Well, a big difference there, aside from all
sorts of other differences, is that in more
traditional societies, people tend to live
near where they grew up and near their family
most of their lives.
In the United States, it's increasingly uncommon.
Was there something garnered from the study
related to that about those who kind of stay
what we might call close to home versus those
that don't?
Speaker 2: What we found was a difference
in the inner city group from the Harvard group.
And that made a whole lot of sense because
the Harvard group was gathered from all over
the country.
Harvard College brings in undergrads from
everywhere in the U.S. and sometimes abroad.
Unlike the inner Citigroup, where they were
chosen because they lived in Boston, their
families lived in Boston.
And what we found then in the next generation
was that, of course, more of the inner city
group lived in this area, stayed near their
families.
Now, what we have not done is an analysis
that compares are those second generation
people in the inner city group happier then
more widely dispersed Harvard people?
I expect that research exists.
We just haven't done it.
Speaker 1: Interesting in terms of the relationships.
Lots of studies on friendship that look at
number of friends, but also quality of relationship.
And what you see frequently repeated in popular
publications is it's not about having many
friends as one ages, it's about having a few
very strong or rewarding relationships that
really seems to correlate not only with happiness,
but sometimes even like a health claim will
be made.
What about that distinction?
Speaker 2: Well, what we find is that, you
know, as with so many things, when you follow
thousands of lives, one size never fits all.
So we're all on a spectrum, temperamentally,
from introversion, shyness to extroversion.
And most of us are somewhere in the middle.
But there are extremes.
And what we find is that shy people find lots
of people around them to be stressful.
So actually having a lot of connections in
your life could be more stressful if you're
temperamentally introverted.
On the other hand, extroverted people get
their energy from people, so they may need
a lot of people.
So what we find is that it's a highly individual
matter and that each of us can really discern
for ourselves what's the amount of connection
that works for me in my life and how can I
work to have the amount that feels right to
me?
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
I mean, holding all else equal.
Do you know whether introverts or extroverts
seem to be happier?
Speaker 2: I don't know that.
I do know that, for example, Susan Kane, some
of her work that there are people who work
on this and I don't believe people have found
that introverts or extroverts are happier
than the opposite extreme at all.
I think one of the complicating factors is
that our culture glorifies extroversion.
You know, being a party animal, right?
You know, that's like an iconic character
in films and literature on social media.
Right.
And so that bias toward extroversion can make
introverted people feel like there may be
something wrong with them.
What we know is there isn't anything wrong
with them at all.
It's perfectly normal, adaptive.
Some of the most wonderful, most brilliant,
most talented people are shy.
Not a problem.
Speaker 1: The book is called The Good Life
Lessons from the World's Longest Scientific
Study of Happiness.
We've been speaking with the book's coauthor,
Dr. Robert Waldinger.
Really appreciate your time and insights today.
Speaker 2: Thank you for having me.